this is a public meeting that's being
videoed it will be available to watch or
review some point a next day or so on
the council website should you wish to
do so I can also ask members of the
public to turn off their mobile phones
as well please before we go any further
can I have two people at the top the
table to just introduce themselves
starting on the right hand side please
committee services major - legal
services Richard Gardiner planning
manager James Hodgkins plodded Daley
Wilson planner yes go back to Richard
for a second Thank You mr. chairman
just to clarify my role here tonight as
I said I'm the planning manager my role
is as an impartial adviser to the
committee and I can clarify any planning
issues that arise doing so I'm bound by
the code of Professional Conduct to the
Royal Town Planning Institute and
planning committee members not bound by
the case offices recommendation or by
any oral advice thank you very much
Richard
okay we go to our first item apologies
for absence please Thank You Joanna got
apologies from councillors brain bills
and O'Donnell and substituting we have
counselors Lorton and Williams thank you
very much well council Orton welcome
back council Williams thank you for
being here tonight disclosure of
interest it's item to counts Lipari good
evening chairman I'd like to disclose an
an interest in application 17 4/0 three
two three nine forward slash very I
should be farm the hollows long Compton
there is a conflict of interest through
my work situation so you I will be
stepping down from the committee thank
you very much council Crump just the
item number okay sorry the thing was
with item number four I was previously
Ward member and part of the Town Council
that objected there is only so to avoid
any accusations of predetermination I
will be stepping down from the item but
we'll be reading a statement from
accounts the Bromwich
participe the world member how you can't
attempt and obviously I'll only written
statement I won't be there for questions
that's great thank you very much
counselor Crump
any other declarations of interest it's
okay I've got my snow boots in the car
I'm sure you have a great time
bring your sledge right minutes from 7th
of February do I have the approval to
sign those thank you always in favor
thank you very much I'll do at the end
of the meeting right so we can go to our
first item tonight's item 4 is on page
seven of your agendas this application
reference 17 / 0 2 6 1 4 / REM is to the
land of Landers Croft
Salim this is a reserved matters
application for the for the appearance
landscaping layout into scale 51
dwelling residential development and an
Associated provision of public open
space presenting officer Louise Coleman
over to you thank you chair prior to the
meeting
this evening a site visit has been
conducted which is attended by the ward
member castle bromwich and also counts
the fielding members walk through the
site enabling them to appreciate the
relationship of the site with its
surroundings and also viewed the site
from their joining public footpath to
the south the application sites
identified by the black dot on the map
is located on the area of land situated
on the western edge of south and town
outline planning permission has already
been granted for the erection of 51
dwellings granted under Planning
Commission 15 for stroke 0 to 0 for 7
forward stroke o UT and the means of
access was a matter of consideration at
that stage a single vehicle access to
the site of the north eastern corner of
the site from here has been approved and
the application before members this
evening is for reserved matters with the
appearance landscape layout in scale to
be considered the site identified by the
red line
plan it sits in between residential
development known as Monday's craft to
the south and holliwell Road and mill
present to the north a complex known as
what ins Lodge lies to the east which is
a sheltered housing complex and
agricultural land lies to the remaining
southern and western boundaries the
southwestern portion of the site which
is denoted by the bold blue line here
forms part of a wider area restraint
also there is an historic sorry
scheduled ancient monument known as holy
the Holy Well which is also a listed way
to listed building South and
conservation area lies approximately 100
meters to the east of the site
identified by the pink line and also
whilst there's no public footpaths that
run within the site itself there is a
network of public footpaths immediately
adjoining there is a public footpath and
these are denoted by the hatched green
lines on the plan one which runs along
the southern boundary of the site and
also there are some which are just off
the plan here in the northwestern corner
the River Slough also runs to the south
the site comprises of 2.5 hectares of
agricultural land and has a slope in
topography which rises in a northerly
direction with a change of level
approximately sixteen and a half meters
tree and hedgerow planting is confined
to the northern and western boundaries
of the sites and the eastern and
southern boundaries are defined by
various temps types of fencing the
layout which is proposed is identified
in the plan before you the development
closely follows that of the indicative
layout submitted in support of the
outline permission the majority of the
development France
to a single road running from west to
east and residential development is
largely confined to the eastern part of
the site with five bungalows extending
to northwestern part of the site however
this is outside of the area of restraint
landscape buffers are proposed along the
western and southern boundaries of the
site and this area is identified to form
a substantial area of incidental open
space with a new foot public footpath
link onto the public with a new footpath
link onto the public footpath which we
runs along the southern boundary an
attenuation Bart pond is also proposed
in the southwestern corner and a mix of
one two three and four pet dwellings are
proposed with 35% of the dwellings being
affordable no good show you some
elevations of their house types that are
being presented now I'm only going to
show you a sample of them however I have
got all of them if members wish to meet
to refer to any the what we've got
before you is and one of the
four-bedroom properties the dwellings
themselves are proposed to be
constructed a number of different brick
types with contrasting roof tiles
details include the use of chimneys
porches heads and stills using
contrasting brick or reconstituted stone
into the use of sunbae windows as is on
this this design and this property in
particular is double fronted which
provides interest on the two of the key
elevations this is an elevation of floor
plan of the proposed one bed maze and X
of the form 1 by X this is elevation of
the to bed bungalows which are proposed
on the northwestern corner of the site
and this is a 3 bedroom property the
design and form of the dwellings is
considered to reflect the local
vernacular in particular within Montes
croft
just going to now
refer to a video Bridgette provided off
the site alright taking from again this
is the eastern boundary of the site
sorry apologies that's the northern
boundary of the site here this is the
eastern boundary and this is forming
part of the southern boundary now the
access I have got a photograph to show
it is located in this position here I'm
panning around now showing the rears of
the properties which are but the site
amanda's croft you can appreciate the
sloping topography of the site again
these are some of the properties the
rears of Mondas craft and then we are
looking towards some of the footpath
network which is located within the
vicinity of the site and I will be
showing you a photograph taken from one
of the footpaths in the southwestern
corner here shortly
panning around now and this is a view of
the western boundary of the sites all of
this existing landscaping is proposed to
be retained and enhanced
turning now to some photographs of the
site itself this is a view taken from
rottens lane which leads into mantas
Croft itself this is the proposed access
this has taken from within the site and
the access point is proposed to be
derived here as I say that has already
been approved as part of the outline
this is a view taken from the public
footpath network to the south of the
site so this area here is proposed to be
retained as open space and with built
form with the five bungalows located
along this area here again this isn't an
alternative view from the southern
footpath link again showing the race of
the existing properties and Landis craft
this is taken from the South Western
footpath so it is a long distance view
the bold blue line indicates
approximately the position of the area
of restraint within the development and
so development would be nestled within
this area here and also extending along
this area here and finally this is a
view taken for one of the footpaths on
the north western part of the site so
the application is using these trees as
reference points so this would be
remaining open but there'd be bungalows
situated behind here there are a number
of updates to note on the update sheet
and the recommendation is to grant
planning permission subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed in the
report thank you - Thank You Louise
okay we go to our first speaker on this
application and mr. mark gave Lee's the
applicants agent
welcome right so you have three minutes
if you'd remain seated for any questions
at the end
that's okay and should I give you a
warning in the final ten seconds thank
you hello my name is Mark gay and I
represent a field homes the applicant
the principal of the residential
development of 51 dwellings including
access has been established by the
site's
outline planning percent their former
comments this evening focused primarily
on the detail relevant to this reserved
matters application the layout has
proposed principally reflects the master
plan agreed with the council at the
outline stage as before most of the
development is focused upon the eastern
thinner filler part of the site with the
exception of five single-story bungalows
as proposed on the science north western
edge in accordance with the prior
positive determination of the outline
application and the extent of existing
dwellings along Holywell road to the
north these bungalows will be cited
before approximately one hectare of new
publicly accessible open space to
reflect the existing open character of
this part of the site the wider area of
restraint and Holywell walk all existing
boundary treatments and vegetation will
be retained and where appropriately
supplemented including a substantial new
landscape buffer along this night's
western boundary as well as interspersed
trees and wildflower meadow planting
within the public open space as a result
of this and associated positive
amendments made during the application
process it is considered that there will
be no harm to the seldom Holywell aura
setting a view shared by your offices
and historic England the view northward
across this part of the site will also
be improved the mix of dwellings
proposed upon the site is varied and
broadly in accordance with the council's
preferred housing mix the site provides
the required 35% affordable housing
which has been appropriately distributed
throughout the development additionally
having had input into the application
design and amendment process
Warwickshire County Council considered
as a safe and suitable parking and
access is available throughout the site
the development has been designed to
read as a continuation of Manda's Croft
to reflect the local architectural
vernacular and height and local distinct
yes accordingly architectural features
such as chimneys porches wet verges
varying brick and child tile choices and
post brick and reconstituted stone
window heads and cells have been
proposed ensuring a high quality of
design to ensure the privacy of existing
residents all necessary separation
distances which have been increased
appropriately to account for any
topographical variation have achieved
have been achieved and in many instances
exceeded Gables site on to existing
Landers Croft properties with all
habitable window they haven't been
removed as such existing resident
privacy and amenity has been
appropriately preserved throughout the
application process we twice met with
South and Town Council to discuss and
explain our proposals as such today the
Town Council
do not object the detail of this
application a field homes that are a new
small house builder established off the
back of central government's ambition to
strengthen the role small house builders
playing housing delivery our focus is
upon both quality and delivery ten
seconds and I politely request that you
approve this application in accordance
with your officers recommendation thank
you any questions please yes councillor
Perry good evening mr. Gary goonie
I've just got two points I wonder
whether you could perhaps the help out
on obviously your you've come new to to
this particular site and there were
references in the committee report
making reference to a change of mix of
housing and the layout and design can
you just be specific in terms of where
the differentials lie that's my point
one and if I'm a chairman point two if
you could just confirm the caliber of
broadband that you will be delivering to
the homes and the speed of broadband to
the homes thank you
okay and if it helps as well I'm
Hayfield homes are new to this site and
however the Hayfield homes is set up
from the Board of managing directors and
directors thank you and your Hayfield
homes has been established from bana
homes Midlands managing directors and
directors who were involved in the
original Manda's craft development and I
was actually also the planning manager
at Karla homes who looked after the
outline application for this site so
there's a great deal of knowledge and
understanding of this sites in our team
albeit hate-filled homes are new to the
process and in terms of differentials in
the layout it is broadly in accordance
with the master plan
I think the key area of difference is
the properties on the far right hand
side as you come into Amanda's Croft and
originally the linear development all
the way along the northern boundary
right up to the eastern boundary
however those four properties there have
now been reoriented so that they follow
the north-south line of Amanda's Croft
as you come up through the development
otherwise the landscape are along the
western boundary is as per the master
plan and as is the separation distances
and landscaping proposed on the southern
boundary and and the general arrangement
and form is has previously submitted Oh
in terms of broadband and I can't
remember off the top of my head what the
speed is but I know that we looked at
the council's requirements and capacity
is available within the area to meet the
requirements we did submit I think of
communications document along with our
application which confirms that in
writing clarification later
council bonds people I couldn't go to
this RV itself Nina went this morning
look this situation is there anything
more you can do the County Council
opposes the ones around the new gig
they you know we've had three or four
goes I do feel that have we got here I
do is the more you can do caps the bands
I would have to come in there of course
access has been established already and
is not part of this application because
of course the principle of the
development already established the
access a lot of the lessons about
parking on site and I'm not convinced
that falls under the under this part of
the committee over this part of the
application sings it's already been
established any other question counselor
Lawton Thank You chair just a couple
words and it does relate to access which
my point is more about the
deliverability because looking through
my notes and they've been quite a lot of
comments from members of the public
about the the right-of-way across
existing maunder to actually get to the
site I mean if there is no right-of-way
obviously the scheme Falls I mean I'm
looking for some comfort that this has
been addressed and there was a meeting
held between myself as the planning
officers and councillor Bromley to
discuss that particular concern and we
have say unfortunately as Bala Holmes
former employees at a field homes our
technical director was actually in
charge of producing the conveyance plans
which ultimately fade into the land
ownership surrounding the access and so
we both have undertaken our due
diligence as the land to ensure we have
the necessary and it relates to actually
should we be mind you to grant this the
actual construction okay in my notes it
looks like you've made an offer to south
and Town Council about a potential
alternative site access I mean I am
concerned that this is a big development
going through an existing residential
development I'd certainly if there was
an opportunity to do that I'd certainly
like you to comment on it and whether we
can discuss it with the officer well
later on if it's if it's an alternative
access of course we need to make a keep
in mind this application has already
established the access point yes Sharon
this is a temporary
it's for construction only look on page
11
my understanding is a suggestion from
the applicant that it would be possible
for an alternative construction if it
would help I want to double-check on
this before we go further hold on just a
second just because we've received an
application for an alternative
construction access it's not been
validated yet but that's an application
that will go out to consultation in the
normal way but it's not something that
has an impact on tonight's application
okay fine I just wanted to establish
though because there was a point in the
papers but it doesn't form any part of
this application it only confirms okay
thank you sorry counts a lot as well
make sure that we're dealing with what's
on the paper from your right yes
counselor feeling the planting boundary
are you just gonna be you're not are you
putting trees in there because I'm
concerned about the sunlight into the
gardens of the people are already living
in the houses to the north side it's
predominantly a hedgerow that's going to
create the northern boundary landscaping
and there are some isolated trees
indicated to be consistent with the
lower level species of trees that are
already present along that northern
boundary so we're not planting anything
that's going to grow to a substantial
height and impact on right of light it
follows the existing and species
diversity on the site and along that
boundary one thing that did concern me
on site was the slope of the ground and
the effect of the pond on the bottom
left-hand corner some way of can you
just reassure me that there is going to
be proper terracing and drainage yes and
we've submitted a comprehensive level
strategy with this application including
street scene drawings to demonstrate
exactly how all the properties are going
to be terrorists and we acknowledge that
it is a topographically varied site and
in doing so that information was
requested by your planning officer
to inform this application so that at a
comprehensive details and decision can
be made and in terms of the balancing
pond that will be done to the council
standards to adhere to greenfield runoff
rate plus a 40% allowance for climate
change today at seven Trent have not
objected to the application and the
exact detail of that balancing problem
will have agreed through an outline
planning condition and attached on the
other planning thank you if there are no
further questions mr. Gaye thank you
very much for your time we can then go
to counselor
Crump who is standing in for council
branch Catholic Ron you know the routine
yet you've got five minutes to count
subbranches statement first of all cast
of romics would like to apologize not
being able to attend tonight as
unfortunately he wasn't able to get
cover for his foster child I mean looked
at the current liens for the application
I I have serious concerns about parking
while there's sufficient parking on the
plans for two or three-bedroom homes I
do not believe that there's sufficient
parking for any larger sized homes nor
is there any parking provision for
visitors
unlike the existing a site I can't
foresee that the road running through
the state will end up becoming a
haphazard single trap road causing
problems for delivery drivers emergency
vehicles refuse collections visitors and
residents like I would respectfully ask
that the committee bear this in mind and
if need be ask for a redesign to
incorporate a road more in line with
castle policy and consider the impact of
past developments whereby no thoughts
have been given to parking provision and
the future development whereby the
council is seeking to ensure
free-flowing more environmentally
friendly Road layers
I would strongly urge deferring or
rejecting if the developer seeks to
carry on with this exist among the five
bungalows in the application are the
buildings were the most impact on the
area of restraint the committee should
consider the past planning inspection
appeal on area of the straits in
particular the one regarding ship stone
pond star where the application was
granted because there was no significant
impact on the view of the area of
restraint the appeal inspector made it
clear that this was not a president but
should be viewed on a case-by-case basis
in line with the policy of the district
council which allows for the limited
development of areas of restraint
whereby no suitable alternative is
available I would learn for us the
committee to consider the removal of
these bond glows there were six on the
outline plan there are no five of which
in the South Amer weather is little or
no demand for your reference bond grows
have not been something particularly one
and save them due in part to the high
level of over fifty five accommodation
currently available in the town
furthermore where the bomb blows are
cited they are a long way from the shops
accessing the shops the town centre
Rivard to extremely steep hills so they
are not particularly suitable for the
intended residence of those properties
when considering the application the
committee should also know that while
saying that they have rights of white
who are the proposed site entry points
the developer has filed produce any
supporting documentation I would suggest
to the committee that without such proof
then the application is deferred until
this is provided as I believe there
could be risk and no matter how small of
potential legal action given this was on
my objection on behalf of residents
in the area over six months ago and
having raised concerned with the
planning officer for at other than core
I believe she did us with such proof the
developer has a ample time to provide
such documentation and that's about it
really
apologies for the lack of commas and
punctuation thank you very much
Thank You councillor Crump okay of
course council can't take questions
because it's not his horse so we'll let
you step down now thank you so points of
clarification yes councillor Perry thank
you can the officers just give confirm
the width of the road running through
the site and also confirm their views on
on the parking which obviously has been
raised this evening Louise most measures
the road I'll give you on the parking
its us in your agenda top of page 16
you'll see that for all two and three
bed properties on here there's a minimum
of two car parking spaces per property
for all of the four bed properties
there's three spaces for those obviously
as a council we've got draft parking
standards and that's gone out to
consultation about the part of our SPD
officers are referred in that limited
weight because of the early stage in the
consultation but I think it's
significant that the levels of parking
are meet those standards in terms of the
on-site provision for each property I
can also confirm the width road is five
point five meters yes Castle Williams
can you just confirm this problem that
member there is a issue for access
although things have the highways
commented about that issue
the matter of access in terms of whether
it's possible to do it legally obviously
that's a private matter and the
developer would have to secure access
possibly over third-party land but
that's not a planning consideration in
terms of the access that's already been
fixed an outline the county highway
authority are happy with obviously that
proposal because that's been granted but
they're also happy with the actual
layout that you see in front of you it's
are just a subrogee there were issues
about Refuge cops not being able to
negotiate this estate the Highways
commented about that and the Highways
Authority would take that into account
because the roads been built and
adoptable standard so they'd be
acceptable whipped and acceptable
turning heads for the Mercedes vehicle
councillor fielding has any
consideration being given to a turning
circle in front of the end bungalow in
order to allow refuge and fire engines
and any large vehicles to turn around
without back down to their Junction it's
not necessary because they would turn
further down where those five bungalow
start you can see effectively t-junction
they could use that to turn and
therefore any residence there would have
their been selected a little bit further
down that makes sense okay any of any
other points of clarification right
should we move to the debate then that's
very might as well start chairman I mean
obviously we're here this evening on the
basis that outline planning permission
has been granted so we are here just to
look at the design and the layout the
access into the site has already been
approved
I appreciate that there are concerns on
a local level by local residents but I
can see no planning reason to refuse
this application chat capsule bounce
you know deputy proposes I actually am
very pleased to see so few bungalows cuz
they're something they're people
you know their bill because they're 72
bedrooms on the same area is a four
bedroom and some songs were appreciate
the pond that was here for the add line
there is a lot of concern
I can many other thing where are these
cars gonna go
we had an estate in that just got
blocked up but there's nothing we can do
up to standard so I'm quite happy to
proposal secondly Thank You councillor
cats a lot Thank You chair yeah I mean
I'm quite happy to second that proposal
I think this is a perfectly acceptable
application I realize that our concerns
about the road layout there might be a
few concerns about the housing make
slime please see it's 35 percent
affordable I personally like to see more
one-bedroom apartments which is emerging
and perhaps in the future applications
that will happen but I'm quite happy to
second the application he seems good to
me
Thank You counsel counsel fielding I
understand the comment about the
bungalows being right down the far end I
would agree with the councillors opinion
that they should be nearer the beginning
of the site so that if they're at the
elderly there it more it's easier for
them to get into the town unless of
course they were down by this 2 foot
path that's the new footpaths being put
in and they can walk more easily but it
is along there are long way but part
from that and I can see no reason why
thank you
right well there's no one else we all
have to go to the vote it's been
proposed and seconded that we approve
the application before us no it's fine
sir all those in favor of approving the
application unanimous chairman thank you
therefore the committee results to
approve application reference 17 / 0 2 6
1 4 /r e M and we can move to our next
application item 5 then is found on page
27 of your agendas tonight and is
application reference 17 / 0 3 3 6 4 /
ful and
the land south of gillip slain upper
brailles this for the erection of
dwelling it's a revised scheme to that
proved under-17 / 0 1 1 / ful and our
presenting officer is allison wilson / -
you don't get quickly ready
Thank You mr. chairman for planning
permission is sought for the erection of
one four bedroom detached dwelling on an
existing parcel of land fronting
Gillette's Lane location is shown by the
black dot the site azimuth calculation
for a brick-built three-bedroom house
and access that was approved by
committee in August 2012 2017 the
application site is a rectangular area
of garden land approximately 30 and a
half meters by 40 meters located on a
private Lane width in the village of
brailles you can also see the
neighboring houses Hollywood House to
the west and Stone Croft which is a
great - listed building to the east here
is a recent aerial view of the site from
the private Lane showing the application
site outlined in red the plot is
approximately 75 metres from the adopted
highway this slide shows the view across
the site from the southern end rear of
the plot looking towards Gillette's Lane
the side of Holly walk house can be seen
on the left-hand side of the picture
this slide shows the view looking to the
rear of the plot this shot slide shows
the side elevation of Hollywood House
these are elevations of the extant
permission for a brick built three-bed
house that was approved by committee in
August 2017 and this that this slide
shows the elevations of the new dwelling
this proposal seeks a revised design so
that the previous to that that was
previously approved it largely sits on
the approved footprint with
approximately the same side separation
distances but the key differences are a
revised appearance stone rather than
brick a larger floor space now four
bedrooms the proposed dwelling is taller
eight meters to the ridge rather than
seven meters the new Ridge is 63
centimeters below the ridge of the
neighboring Holly walk house the chimney
is now on a non-functioning chimney side
facing windows are to be obscured the
West elevation with only ground floor
windows serving toilet utility and
kitchen would face Holly walk house and
the East elevation with only two ground
floor windows secondary windows to the
sitting room would face Stone Croft a
further parking spaces means has been
shown now providing a total of three
parking spaces this this slide shows the
proposed layout the plot is 14 meters
wide where the house is the proposed
dwelling is 9.7 wide resulting in a 2.5
wide space on the west side facing Holly
walk and 1.5 meters on the east this
slide shows the layout of the new
proposals as compared with that
previously approved and this slide shows
Holly walk house next door
mr. chairman there are no updates and
the recommendation is to approve this
application for the reasons detailed in
the report thank you Thank You Alison
okay we go to our speakers on this Sarah
Day please
welcome thank you for waiting so you
also have three minutes if you remain
seated for any questions at the end and
I'll give you a warning at the last ten
seconds if that's okay if I could ask
you to press the button to turn the
microphone on perfect thank you over to
you the modest three-bedroom cottage has
now morphed into a greatly increased
sized building 46% larger footprint and
a meter higher all the pictures that you
have been shown failed to take into
consideration the relationship of this
building in relationship to the listed
building the reason why I'm here is
especially to speak tonight it's
concerning access information provided
to the Planning Committee at the
original meeting was based on inadequate
and inaccurate information firstly a
planning application for this plot was
made some years ago by the applicants
family it was dismissed on appeal by the
visiting expense inspector a substandard
Road incapable of bear least capable of
serving existing dwellings the road
remains substandard fragile with a
veneer tarmac surface visible breaks
neither the design statement nor
construction management plan consider
this substandard road or that residents
are supposes responsible for maintenance
and costs what has changed since that
original planning application is
Warwickshire guy 2002 one trance water
roads developments which states it's the
council's responsibility to assess all
developments where there are
implications for access of vehicles and
pedestrians in its Lane is a public
footpath
it states that careful consideration be
given to deciding the number of
dwellings that any private single track
should access or serve no assessment has
been made by highways otherwise it would
become obvious that it was not suitable
that state there should be no more than
five residences in a private no through
road in its Lane has ten residents the
bone mouse referred to in the report
does not exist
ie a space where two vehicles can pass
each other at the entrance ilet's Lane
is less than 3.8 minutes as a entry
certainly no space to park vehicles to
pass then no turning facilities does not
meet the required access for a fire
engine with a minimum width width of 3.5
meters the the lane is in sections at
only 2.9 meters wide there's no separate
footpath for pedestrians the Road
Traffic Act 1988 states that a public
for a vehicle a use of a public footpath
requires lawful authority the Highways
consultation with highlighted the
planning authorities need to establish
that a vehicle access which had lawful
authority was in place this was not done
in spite of strong third party evidence
refutes evidence refuting the claimed
access the agents claim to an existing
access with a legal right of access
declared on the application remains
unsubstantiated
in conclusion billets lane is well below
current planning standards to support a
new residential dwelling or intelligence
the safety of pedestrians I therefore
say that the planning application not be
granted and in respect of planning
standards that planning application 17 1
1 1 on which this current planning
application rests is reconsidered I
don't have to stop you there that's the
end of your time if you remain seated
for any questions thank you does anybody
from the committee have any questions
yes counselor krub yes fire-engines the
requirements now for a new dwelling is
that you need a minimum Road with a 3.5
meters and
turning facility in any dead-end the
width of the dis Lane in sections is
only 2.9 meters and there's absolutely
no turnin facility any further questions
that gets missed a thank you very much
Thank You next speaker which is Jane
Cashmore agent for the applicant please
welcome so ya know the routine it's
three minutes you remain seated for any
questions over to you thank you good
evening
last August this committee granted
permission for one dwelling on the
application site I carefully listened to
your debate at that committee and the
comments you made have been taken into
account in this revised proposal given
there is an exempt permission for a
dwelling on the site it's appropriate to
focus on the changes between that
permission and the development now
proposed amongst various matters debated
several members commented that they
thought the dwelling was of a scale that
was smaller than nearby properties would
be dwarfed by others on Gillett slain
some members were concerned about the
chimney in terms of smoke in the impact
on neighbors the appearance of the
dwelling was discussed and it was noted
that members resolved to grant subject
to ask a condition to obscure glaze the
side facing windows towards stone craft
this proposal seeks a revised design to
that previously approved and allison has
summarized the key differences but in
brief the design now has a more
traditional appearance its flat-fronted
with a forged porch projection and the
war materials are to be local stone
instead of the previously approved brick
the revised design proposes a larger
floor space to provide four bedrooms
this size of property is not out of
keeping with nearby houses on the lane
link to this as it's now a four bed
property an additional off-road parking
space has been provided to provide three
in total and this this meets your
emerging parking standards the chimney
is now a non functioning chimney we
haven't removed it entirely from the
design because we feel it contributes to
the design but the fact it's non fun
means that smoke would no longer be an
issue proposed Rowling is taller but
that it would still be lower than the
adjacent Holly walk house and all
separation distances to neighbors are
met finally the plan showed that the
side facing windows towards stone
crafted to be obscured matters relating
to the principle of development access
arrangements landscaping drainage and
ecology are materially unchanged by the
revised development whilst neighbors
continue to raise matters of access
rights up Gillett slain it is not a
planning matter but a civil matter
sitting outside of planning legislation
that has been clearly set out by your
officer in their report on page 35 I
hope you can see how the applicant has
taken on board your comments and hope
you agree that their now proposed to
dwelling is the visual improvement
compared to the previously permitted
house thank you thank you any questions
for the ward member apologies to the
applicants agents yes
I thought you'd say yeah just the point
that must I raised about the access for
fairness rescue just wonder what your
comments were on that I think if memory
serves me right fire engines and and
such like vehicles was considered in the
previous application and ultimately
worker County Council have raised no
objection to this the lane is currently
serving ten dwellings fire engines would
need to serve those those in the
instance of an emergency fire engines
have blue flashing lights and it's it's
an emergency situation so I don't think
there's a technical reason to refuse the
application for a new dwelling on access
for fire engines given there's an extent
permission in place any further
questions that case thank you very much
right and we now go to our board member
Capps the gray
welcome counselor gray Thank You
Jeremiah puntilla I'm here in supporting
the neighbors and residents of Gibbs
Lane who are opposing an application and
and thank you for hearing them for my
part I have a couple of things that I'd
like to I'd like to mention the listed
building next door stone Croft will be
dwarfed by the new building building
which has a rich height some five meters
above it as due to the size of the new
building and the slope of the ground but
it makes the new very clearly visible of
ustym stone Croft when viewed from the
main road the officers report highlights
erza for me to hi Beach hedge on the
stonecrop property which protects the
setting but it seems wrong to me that
the owner of Stone Croft might feel
obliged to maintain this hedge at that
height in order to protect the setting
my second area of difficulty is given
slain itself too narrow for vehicles to
pass nowhere to turn around and even
before use a smaller refuse truck to
collect household waste from the line
there's no facility to repair or
maintain the lane without blocking it
there's no limited access for emergency
vehicles and it depends on the goodwill
of residents to manage the lane and the
more people that use it the more
difficult it will be for the residents
in 1977 chairman an application to build
on this site was refused and
subsequently went to appeal that appeal
was dismissed by an inspector who
considered that the development would
have an adverse effect on the
residential enjoyment of the dwellings
in the lane through increased vehicular
activity chairman there's already
permission to build a three-bedroom
house on this site increasing the size
of the dwelling increases the pressure
on Gillett slain on its neighbours and
on the setting of the listed building I
hope that a three-bedroom house in this
location can be considered adequate
thank you thank you cathode ray any
questions for the ward member council
Williams
I'm just a little bit comfor confused
you're quoting the listed building but
when you consider the photographs we
short saw there was a very new building
on the left-hand side of the site I
think that was that photograph taken
from the rear of the site and is holy
walk house that the other side
listed buildings on the other side yeah
that house sits above the further up the
lane perhaps which is very quickly
identify which buildings were talking
about so we know can you show us on the
map
please Alison just so we know where
there is the list of building that
fronts onto the highway the red line at
the top of the picture is the
application site towards the bottom of
the picture around here that's the house
that I just showed you so that's the
listed building of the building with the
access of the main road with a driveway
and a courtyard fronting onto the
highway so this is Gillette's Lane and
all the properties up and down
Jeanette's Lane face onto gelatin that's
Lane along the main road they all face
so the brick built building that council
Williams is referring to is thank you
very much okay sorry to interrupt that
any other questions for the ward member
please
in that case counselor great thank you
very much okay points of clarification
anyone yes counselor crop it was touched
on earlier
but I received an email from must die
regardless site I'm sure I did and I'm
not sure whether any other councillors
did so I think we were to death okay a
couple of people receive those that okay
we make sure we've noted that in the
declarations of interest thank you
you have any other points clarification
yes just took them on the the fire
engine issue just what again Alison's
comments were and whether you actually
received any comments from walk so far
in rescue because they are separate hi
something throughout the last plane a
professional is planning application
they've raised no objections to the
proposals I have clarified gone back
something clarified a few specific
questions including the emergency
vehicles on Gillette's Lane specifically
and I'll read you out their reply hi
Allison the situation would remain
unchanged for emergency vehicles they
will access the lane in the same way as
they do now it is unlikely that the
addition of an additional dwelling would
increase the likelihood of the need for
access by emergency services and I doubt
very much that there have been very many
visits in recent years that have caused
an issue at one point because it's from
quite a link closely related it was
raised by most day that there'd been no
assessment by the Highways Department is
that correct or has there been a proper
assessment come to take a visited the
site as well thank you sorry counselor
feeling I got I have got an email from
with mr. day when I noticed what it was
about I didn't read it because that is
irrelevant to our discussions Thank You
counselor councillor Perry Thank You
chair can the office just give some
indications as any consideration being
given to the construction management
plan in view of the concern about the
lane as because I don't see it down on
the recommendations if we were minded to
approve through Chur its conditioned 13
apologies it's written as an acronym cmp
that's construction management plan
apologies for that
Thank You chairman could you just
I'm just want to Claire about the roof
Heights obviously this in your
application is a meter higher than the
one that's already got excellent concern
it obviously doesn't affect Stonehaven
but it's been intimated here that
affects the building to the to the West
called the null or not could you comment
on those it considerably higher than the
novel this new building it's north on
the other your your picture I wasn't
sure whether it was higher than stone
Croft or higher than Knoll okay sorry
okay yeah so Holly walk out is it is it
such a taller than Hollywood hands slope
okay the new house is still lower than
the ridge of Holly walk house in the
previous scheme it was one point six
meters lower I think in this scheme I
think it's 0.8 meters lower okay fine I
in the previous scheme there was a lot
of discussion because there was a
chimney on the on the side faces Holly
walk house but in the revised proposals
that's now a non-functioning to me so
there'll be no smoke drifting in that
direction okay
again that so the height difference is
on the whole
Road is on a slope yes any other
poo-poos clarification council williams
heard from two speakers no mentioning of
an appeal when I look at the records I
don't see any information about that
do you have details all that appeal I
think the appeal that is being referred
to is dates back to 1977 and it's on the
site opposite all right council bonds
then council fielding am I am I correct
in saying that lady spoke about all the
rules and regulations the highways are
happy because it's a private road it's
not the reason always they do happy that
is okay so it is a private road or is it
I suppose adopted by the I think they've
they primarily take the stance of
assessing the point that the private
road meets the adopted highway but and
they've assessed that there's no highway
safety impacts on the public highway but
I think their view is the addition of
one additional dwelling in this
situation will be making that negligible
difference
okay any other quotes clarification we
go to the debate then council fielding I
was unhappy with this scheme when it
came forward the first time both forum
access for getting materials onto the
site at the time there was discussions
about coming in from the road next to
refer to as the house on the south side
but I gather that that access has now
been closed or sold off it is a very
narrow track up there it's very it
hasn't been properly maintained
I see no good reason for enlarging what
at the time I thought was a very
difficult site to develop so my my basic
feeling is it hasn't
and I'm loathe to allow it to increase
in size
okay councillor Williamson mr. chairman
I'd be happy to propose this site I can
see no material reasons why we should
not support the application I think all
these questions about the exits along
the barrowed they're quite a lot of
houses along there already so what
happens to them if they were fire I
don't think on additional house was
breaking the deal I'd be quite happy to
support this deal I think it meets all
our regulations thank you can't swim so
I'll take that as a proposition accounts
with our bonds yes I do remember it
coming before and the same sort of
discussions I've got a road whether it
was a fire and if that's Cottage Meadow
Road half way back the same distance is
this thing and the fire engine just
stopped in the middle the road ranked
the bog down so I appreciate that
difficulty in rural areas that as far as
I'm concerned the building looks
probably better than one before I'm
quite happy to be proposing it's already
been proposed you happen so happy to
second it thank you
okay councillor Perry thank you chair on
the basis that obviously the site has
got planning permission for a smaller
dwelling but it's in red brick it's
welcome to see this application come
forward using local stone which I feel
is far more in keeping with other
properties within the vicinity and I
can't see any material planning reason
to refuse it and attention has been
given to the design to take into account
concerns that were raised on the
previous application and therefore I
will be supporting the offices
recommendation
thank you nobody else wishes to speak I
think I agree with the previous speakers
afraid which is to say that I think the
application has improved it is bigger
but I think I think this actually is
will sit better within the landscape
actually so I will support the officers
as well we have to go to the vote so
there are no updates recommendation is
to grant all those in favor please show
5 Chairman those against and abstentions
tea chairman thank you
therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference 17/2 zero
three three six four slash ful and on
the move to item six on tonight's agenda
okay item six is found on page 41 of the
agendas tonight and is application
reference 17 / 0 3 3 4 4 / o UT and it's
the land north of Baltimore Elaine light
on to the outline application for three
dwellings associated infrastructure and
the provision of open space presenting
offices James Hodgkins James over to you
thank you Jeff
yeah the application site is located to
the east of the village of light horn as
denoted by the black dot the application
is an outline application with all
matters reserved except for access for
the erection of three dwellings and also
the provision of a landscape buffer
members may recall a similar application
for three darlings was refused by
committee in February 2017 but the
landscape buffer has been the additional
element to this proposal here the site
just shows that the site's outlined in
red and you can see there's a public
footpath that does cut through the site
here and the conservation area is just
located to the north the site doesn't
actually fall within the conservation
area so just got a variable view of the
site here along this applicated Brian's
a proposed to the north of Mortimer lane
and like one village is located there to
the east so the site does slope up from
water more Lane the lung levels do rise
quite significantly which hopefully be
demonstrating some of the photos I've
got to to show you here and this just
shows the the differentiation so the
dwellings located on the right and in
this landscape buffer which is the
difference in the application type this
is an indicative image obviously as the
application is acting outlined at the
moment but it just gives an idea of how
the applicant proposes to situate the
dwellings and again this is just an
indicative image of how the drawings
could look if the scheme was to go
forward just got some photos just from
one water more lane looking into the
site and with the land rising this way
up here
and this shows the edge of the sights
that this would be the potential
landscape buffer and this is the view
from the nearest neighbor and just the
longer the delay in itself with the site
on the left the upward the
recommendation is to refuse as outlined
within the officers report there has
been an update that is about which
should have been received thank you
thank you
our first speaker then is counselor Andy
Smith lifelong parish council welcome
councillor Smith good to see you again
so you have three minutes you know the
routine over to you supports this
application in arriving at this we have
consulted with the applicant and some of
the neighbors who have commented the
majority of comments are in support of
the application and there are no
objections from the statutory penalties
in his report the planning officer
refers to housing member stating that
this application would not result in an
over provision of housing for light on
the implication being that light horn is
expected to take at least this number of
new houses space for new development
within the village is severely
constrained and in considering
applications the Parish Council looks
for sites that will complement existing
built form we feel that this site meets
that criterion built-up area boundaries
are currently under consultation and
therefore not defined the Parish Council
responded to the consultation requesting
that this site be included in the VAB
for light on the planning officer
acknowledges that there is no current
defied be UAB this notwithstanding given
the constraints on space for new
development it is likely that any new
provisions will have to extend the
boundary as has been seen with previous
recent developments that are less
sympathetic to the established form in
this application under Section G of the
core strategy the local needs
James cs50 it allows for development
within and adjacent to settlements the
planning officer has concerns over the
prominence of the proposed dwellings due
to the sloping nature of the site we
feel that this is overstated as the
valley setting mitigates the overall
prominence it is a defining
characteristic of light form but it lies
in a valley with the majority of houses
being on a hillside this place is
considering importance on new builds
being sympathetic to the center to the
setting and the Parish Council believes
that this proposal will achieve that and
will improve the first built form as
seen when approaching along more and
more laying the Parish Council accepts
that light or must accommodate new
dwellings but after the Planning
Committee attached significant weight to
our wishes as to where they should be
placed please approve this application
Thank You counsel
any questions capsule Perry good evening
mr. Smith and obviously there's some
open space attached with this site to
the left of the proposed three dwellings
can you just advise or can you just
update me where else within that part of
the village is the some open space for
other villages open space for what
purpose for you just people to be able
to to enjoy I don't actually live in the
village itself so I'm just going from
memory of the site now we have the
village green in the middle and the
varies but around the mediate area I I'm
afraid I can't answer that CATSA Barnes
is most of the village in the
conservation area yes so
yes okay counselor Crump go on counts
the bonds come one reason very few sir
was cutting down trees well is there a
lot of the trees there could I do to
look at it and the planning officer
makes in the update the update removes
the objection on the grounds of damage
to the trees oh yes okay counselor come
no counsel Smith um if the bear with me
can you remind me of the status of your
neighborhood plan we have a village plan
we don't have a neighborhood plan yes
okay thank you and is this in your
village plan now is this an area that
has been set aside for for building and
would you have support the empties
obviously I know you're here supporting
but in the village plan is it an area
you would support building it I'm afraid
you know stretching my recollection of
that document yeah don't worry that's
fine there are no further questions
councillor Smith thank you very much for
your time our next speaker then is andy
wilkinson to the applicant both mr.
Wilkins you also have three minutes
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end and I'll give you a warning at
last ten seconds if that's okay over to
you good evening chair ladies and
gentlemen my name's Andy workers and we
act on behalf of the applicant mr. Savin
by our own admission the previously
refused submission was very poor in
quality but since we've come on board
our own has been submit the quality
application that addresses the previous
reasons for refusal we commissioned the
landscape and visual assessment this is
written changes to the scheme and his
new evidence that was not available to
uni officers when the previous
application was determined this
documents assists in providing the phone
and authorities for whether or not the
site lies within the village confines
the differences between the last
application and this are the following
the dwelling society
to the road which is more characteristic
of the village the speech scene shows
how the dwellings will be built at the
same floor level as the adjoining
cottages the intent is to build when
have storage volumes from local
limestone and in your open spaces
proposed to create a transitional edge
to the village in perpetuity this will
enhance the landscape and biodiversity
of this end of the village and to policy
matters the critical policy factor is
whether the site lies within the
physical confines of the village the
test laid out in adopted policy is 10 it
is not whether the site lies outside the
draft built-up area boundary as that can
only be given little little weight the
Pointer officers agree upon submissions
we were made by the pc to include the
site within the bu a B the current
policy test is that the site should have
a physical and functional relationship
with the village we the Parish Council
and board member consider this test is
met because the site has always been
part of the immediate land holding of
Churchill farm for many years
it immediately joins existing cottages
to the east it's framed by the existing
development on high ground to the north
and to the south and this development on
high ground is perceived as a settlement
as the settlements edge by users of
public footpaths within the local
landscape and those traveling along
Morton Morel Lane this issue the
physical and functional relationship
with a village is essentially the
judgment call for members to make and
it's quite reasonable for your officers
to judge it differently from me just as
it will be unreasonable for you to judge
it differently from your officers in
terms of the landscape impact we
strongly disagree with the officers
opinion the site lies at the bottom of
the small steep-sided valley the
dwellings will be sited at the same
level as the adjoining cottages a
typical light tone characteristic
excavating works to create a building
platform assist in mitigating any
landscape impact and is again a
characteristic of the village the site
is in fact very well contained by the
higher land form and the houses witness
all quietly within the landscape in a
form again common to the village
in addition and is accepted by officer
the site complies with policy CS 15 and
CS 16 and provides a limited number of
houses on a site with local
ten seconds that contributes towards
lightens housing numbers on this basis I
would ask members to approve this
proposal thank you thank you mr. Wilkins
any questions please agent counsel bonds
correct yes how do we know that the
design that you put forward compared
with you will use you could impose
conditions it's the principle that we're
looking to establish and of course
you'll be responsible for determining
any reserved matters application and
we're stating quite openly here that you
know there's a form that is acceptable
in our in our minds in the landscape and
certain materials are expected to be
used and I don't think you would expect
the parish council the holder member to
support anything different it's okay it
is only the principal of this
development of course you are quite
right and if anything else would come
back as a reserved matters application
counselor fielding we are indicating
correct suitable for agriculture and
it's just basically wasteland yes that's
right and on the first point the
footpath would remain in situ it
wouldn't need diverting yes about the
physical and functional relationship
with the village and you mentioned the
footpath and I couldn't quite hear what
you said I didn't fully understand your
a bit about the footpath in the front
sure physical functions right sorry
probably probably the way I made it our
point was as people using the public
footpaths will view the village it will
be seen as being within the physical
confines of the assessment so if you
actually I mean the the landscape
technical note that we submit
it took into account all the views into
an out of light horn and is actually you
know pretty robust document in terms of
the impact it will have on the
settlement and how it will be seen from
various perspectives Thank You chairman
and looking at the site and it's a big
site you're building three houses is the
reason that you're not building any more
to the left-hand side because of the
footpath or is it because of the
physical nature of the site it's
obviously going a lot of excavation and
fill going on here it is that particular
portion developable I suppose it is
developable but I think we would be
pushing the justification on the
physical confines of the settlement and
we'll be making a in Congress you know
disruption to the settlement which I
know certainly other developments in
light Horne have been accused of making
so we've kept it neat to keep it
confined to the existing settlement
councillor fielding sort of applications
seeing the land form of the site and
it's not a quarry site it follows that
the natural contours of the lands
there's no evidence of any quarry thank
you okay there no further questions
thank you very much mr. Wilkins thank
you okay and now councillor Mills can't
be with us tonight but very kindly
councillor kettle has agreed to read a
statement on his behalf
yeah I have been asked as to be
substitute not to read his statement he
has briefed me fully and I have had
meetings with the applicant and
therefore an up close on point for the
Constitution I would be very happy to
answer questions afterwards and have
been fully briefed and if the members
wanted to ask
I think I'd like to just take a bit of
advice from a strong yes what if that's
okay Mason do you feel he's in a
position to be able to answer questions
given that he's not the world member and
you're happy that that's in line with
the changes to the Constitution yes
counselor Kendall I feel I have to go
with the legal advice I've been given on
the evening and I had to stick to that
here's some not in accordance with the
Constitution which I have got in front
of me but don't worry I just feel that
if we will get into a tune throw about
the Constitution by is chair of the
committee have got to go with my
recommendation we can discuss it another
time I'm sure caster Kelly you've got
five minutes over to you good evening
mr. chairman ladies and gentlemen I'm
sorry I can't be with you tonight I'm
grateful to counsel Chris kettle he'll
be reading my submission this committee
has seen application for this site
before since when the Atkinson carried
out considerable work to address the
concerns of members and officers
although officers have objected Converse
they're like members to note that the
word member of the parish council a
majority of residents responding support
this application be rabies were in draft
form and carried little planning wait at
the stage a matter counselor st. port
folder hold up for planning policy at
full council meeting on the 11th
December and Matthew Neal our policy
officer subsequently have both addressed
the matter is therefore one of judgment
not be you Obi's as to whether this site
thoughts within the confines of the
village or not the private counsel made
representations to SDC didn't draw up
boa boa bees this site this site should
be included within the village they
represented the community they rip so
the community forces in not out it's not
a remote field
it's backlund 10 metres from Valley and
they cottages in [ __ ] below and 27
metres from the seven house of elements
of church record the slope you can see
any officers photos immediately behind
the site is actually brownfield land and
previously redundant pig farms pig bones
now planted with trees if you compare
this site to those on Wellborn Road
which God look at map please
thank you which is the bottom row to the
top of the hill very visible and we move
on with the photographs those two now
not that one on the previous one are
very very prominent this one is not it
is based in the bottom of the valley
overlooking the road like all the other
existing houses in the village the
applicants undertaken a landscape detail
landscape and visual impact assessments
to ensure this design fits into the
village confines and addresses that
landscape impact most of like the home
properties are sitting on banks
overlooking the village road this site
is no different and as for the others to
prototype co-efficient will sit well
within the landscape with the backdrop
of Churchill insuring they will not be
on the skyline this will be the opposite
to the impact have previously shown you
in addition as one drives into the
village long this Lane one currently
sees the 1950s semi-detached houses
which are not we're in line with current
light on design these properties will be
much more different they will be
designed to be sympathetic to the
village the tree issue has been
addressed in the update sheet and
there's no longer a reason for objection
I would note though that the applicant
planted those trees himself 15 years ago
and has every intention of maintaining
as many of them as you can along with
all the other works he's done in
conclusion given the government's recent
press release and on the revised LPF we
have here a local scheme prepared for
the small parish council representing
local community these two dwellings will
reflect and enhance the existing built
environment the village unlike some of
the other developments in Lima the
policy cs9 the proposed that current
application will attract to encourage
younger families to move the village
light horn the application also helps
for to make a positive contribution to
this category for village which has yet
to meet its core structure education of
32 houses and will therefore comply with
policy 16 being a small development the
site will be using local builders and
tradesmen
encouraging the local economy in
accordance with paragraph 55 of the MPP
F supporting the vitality of a local
village there are no objections of
highways or environmental health by
making provision for house sparrows
by incorporating nesting sites and
buildings and the applicant is happy for
this to be conditioned should you be so
minded the application also meets
criteria policy cs6 contributing to the
national natural environment although
there's an outline application the
applicant is very keen to see the use of
appropriate staining the construction of
the new dwellings which will match other
properties in light on light on parish
council supports the very smaller houses
in summary the applicant has gone a long
way to address previous concerns he has
the support of the parish council and
there are no objections for highways or
environmental health I ask you
representing the ward member having
heard from the parish council to support
this application thank you on behalf of
council Christmas
thank you very much thank you very much
ok in that case we can move then two
points of clarification from committee
yes I think you know the question I'm
going to ask all I'm saying is this is
an outline for access and development
can we or can I be advised on what words
we can put that we pictures that we've
got we can include you're asking if we
can attach a note it would be little
more than a request
that's it of course not enforceable
counselor fielding it looks like the
local need properties which are small
enough for young families moving into
the village which is something we've
Adly need local local need restrictions
on these that's not the application has
been submitted it would have to come
back as a different application for that
to be the case I think possibly what the
wall member and this is maybe will serve
a local need but I don't think it's
something that he's requesting any other
points of clarification if we go to the
debate councillor Perry Thank You chair
first of all I'm quite familiar with
this side to happen to live in Morton
morale with friends in light torn so
it's always the shorter way into the
village when there's no snow I also have
to admit that I was a member of the
Planning Committee that refused this
application what I do find in front of
me it's very refreshing to see a more
distinctive design that I appreciate
it's only outline but an indicative plan
and I just feel greater thought has been
given to putting some open space which
knowing liked horn I could do there is
there is a shortage of sort of open
space there I also feel because I know
that particular Road quite well it gives
some more welcoming presence if if if
they went along those particular design
and I think what is particularly
refreshing is that other permission
planning permission for new dwellings in
light tone are exceedingly large and I
can understand why the Parish Council
and the Ward men
and villagers are supporting this
because it is a smaller development my
view is that actually my interpretation
CS 15 5.18 where it does highlight
provision of some new housing in
villages across this strict small scale
to meet the needs of these communities
now I know it's not local need but with
the support that's been given by the
parish council and obviously there's
been extensive consultation on this
particular application I do feel that
that responds to five point one point
eight I also feel a s-10 is applicable
where it reflects to small scale schemes
for housing and it does reflect and it
takes we're taking to consideration form
of local evidence I like to feel that a
parish council meeting where villagers
have been consulted that that is local
evidence so together with that and also
cs9 if we were to look if if the design
if we were able to attach a note because
I think the design is distinctive it
does sit with the character of light
horn I would be in favor of granting
this application Thank You councillor
Perry councillor Barnes and council
Williams yes chairman I did ask the
question about the design as it was a
headline and I'm very pleased that we we
can put a note I think the situation is
that I did know the village when I used
to milk the cows at Morton moral but
they've changed quite a bit
but the conservation area in a village
in my villages has a great detrimental
effect on having a number of houses in a
small plot they all want great big asses
the conservation architect it doesn't
like something that's not in keeping and
that's
so he does push it to a factory where as
this is on the edge of the bridge and I
think a lot of thought has gone into it
and with the conditions that I would
like about the outline being the
development as it is in the outline I'm
quite happy to propose it and with some
of the reasons that can slip the
previous scans to the put in planning
terms so I think a lot of this thoughts
going into it if he's in the village
virtually and I'm happy to propose you
Thank You council balance council
Williams mr. chairman be much talk but
the designer we've got in front of us
not that we have to consider it's an
outline planning permission its policy
and policy only we have to consider I do
know light on there's been talk about
these rambling large houses being built
all the time I know no large house has
been built a burning for six bedrooms of
that sort thing in lightful there has
been some development there is a
development taking place within the
confines of their locations I'm happy
with this development it's supported by
local people it's supported by the
parish council and by the ward member
that's quite an important collection of
people are all supporting it there's
been no objections to it I think we
should bear reference to this support I
think it's also important to realize
that the case officers case against not
envisioned this based purely on fringes
of policies which I don't think have as
much weight it's local opinion and local
demand I'm happy to support this
application cancel Orton thank you thank
you chairman yes I get the mood of the
the members here and I tend to agree it
is a matter of whether this is within
the village boundary the built-up area
boundary whatever as it's been mentioned
it's a conservation covered village it's
very difficult to get houses like
within so I could see the offices point
that it might be outside the village
boundary but in this instance I think it
is like my weight is with the parish
council and with the ward member in
absentia to actually go against the
officers recommendation on this this
particular application I mean I've
mentioned that my concern about this
leading to a further application on on
the left hand side well obviously if
that did happen and it came back to this
committee the committee would weigh it
on on its own merits or lack of Merit so
I'm quite happy to support this
application sunk below the level of the
properties above which are in the
conservation or in the conservation area
it won't be seen or limited visual
aspects the Crump say it's refreshing to
hear that the agent admitted that the
previous application was wrong it's not
your paraphrase in there but it wasn't
physically brilliant obviously a society
classes the road at similar levels and
we consider more defiant to traditional
edge of the village and I think in my
opinion the applicant has demonstrated a
physical and a functional relationship
with the village obviously there's been
quite a lot of support from the ward
member the parish council and also I
think there was eight eight people
supporting so again quite a bit of local
support and again finally I'll support
the open space comments and it is
unusual that the applicant is not trying
to put in as many properties as possible
arm the space and if more needs a ground
I'd like to see if we can ensure that
the open space I think it's to the west
is maintained if possible so again I
think
with most people on the committee I'm
supporting up at a time
I support the application and go against
office recommendation to refuse yes
counselor pounce as I proposed this to
grantees the world to be a condition on
that they if the open space is kept open
no can we have them yes probably best
before members go to the vote
I'm conscious that it's apparent that
members may well overturn the officers
recommendation so if that's to take
place then I'm gonna have to be clear on
the reasons for that so what I'll do is
I'll summarize what I've heard and then
members can vote in the light of that
and I can also provide a list of
conditions and notes from so that
members can take it all as one vote okay
so first in terms of the reasons for any
overturn I haven't heard anything that
would suggest that members are
considering this site to be within the
village confines it's clearly
agricultural land and agricultural land
is the type that would always fall
outside of a village confines so with
regard to that what I'm understanding
from committee is that even though it's
outside the village come finds there are
material considerations that outweigh
any harm arising from that and they fall
into two types the some that can be
given full weight and they would be the
provision of open space provided to the
West they would also be the fact that
this site lies lower the neighboring
properties and therefore doesn't have as
greater impact as it might there are
also reasons that outweigh it that can
be given limited way to namely the
intentions of the applicant to provide a
high-quality distinctive design and
dwellings of a modest size in compliance
with policy cs9
that's my understanding of what where
members are going and the reasons but
for any overturned with regard to
conditions those obviously if members
overturn it I'd be happy to read out a
list of conditions
or agree with you mr. chairman would you
like me to read it and read them out add
one other thing I think just to speak in
the debate on this yeah obviously I do
agree with the rest of the committee I
think for me that the key points maybe I
can say Parian councillor Crump has
somehow made some very good points
backed up by the by the core strategy
but also counts of Crump I think you're
right yeah this application has
definitely demonstrated the links to the
rest of the village I think that for me
has changed my view of the of where this
sits in relation to the built up
boundary is this in or isn't out I think
they've done a much better job this time
of demonstrating how this is within the
built up boundary at the same time I
also think that the provision of the
open open space provides almost a
protection I think to further actually
sort of think it sort of rounds off the
built up boundary of the village quite
well so I think the way it's been
demonstrated in this application as
opposed to the previous one is actually
much much clearer demonstration of how
it sits with light on itself councillor
Perry I know you wanted to come in yes
when I sort of looked at this whenever
hearing the debate etc I do feel this
relevance to policy a s-10 from a
community perspective because it does
state small you know under a small scale
schemes for housing employment or
community facilities to meet a need
identified by a local community orbit in
the parish plan and Abraham or other
form of local evidence and I do feel
that the way the applicant has gone
about obviously with this new agent
doing comprehensive consultation
actually reinforces form of local
evidence and the fact that we've got
local support no objections we've got
local parish support and we have local
ward member support so I do feel policy
a s-10 countryside in villages is
relevant in this particular application
yeah I think I'd agree with that
definitely can sorry okay Richard
summarise
it seems to me that the feeling is that
this is within the village confines and
that there were also material
considerations that weigh in favor of it
namely the provision of open space which
is a buffer and as I said before it's a
lower level than the exact neighboring
properties and the level of local
support which actually provides the
evidence that is 10a requires so it
meets several policies of the plan
together with the limited way that
members can give to the intentions of
the applicant to provide yes okay so
we're all content with that as our
reasons for granting if that's what
we're going to do can we go through the
conditions then very quickly there would
be time limits conditions standard three
standard reserved matters conditions one
of which would be the development
restricted to no more than three
dwellings there were five highways
conditions provision of an access of at
least five meters in width for distance
of seven and a half meters to the near
edge of the carriageway surfacing of the
access with bound material for five
metres visibility splays forty three
meters to the east one hundred and forty
to the west restriction on gates or
barriers and a construction management
plan one ecological condition providing
opportunities for nesting birds two
drainage conditions but no one drainage
condition foul and surface water details
two environmental health conditions land
contamination assessment and remediation
works as a result of that important ones
on landscaping who had been need to be
dieter a condition required details of
the long term management of the land to
the west together with a provision of a
standard soft landscaping condition
provision of a tree survey which has
already been done so that would be that
would fall away because it's been
provided this week tree protection
measures would be a condition proposed
site levels and then other types of
conditions bin storage water Bert's
electric vehicle charging points and
approved plans and finally the note
request from this committee that they
design on reserve matters to be in line
with the plans that they've seen tonight
the committee happy okay we've got a
proposal from from Council Barnes needs
it second and of course councilor Perry
to the second
this is anything else should go to the
vote all those in favor of granting the
application as stated in that case the
committee results to grant application
reference 17/2 zero three three four
four slash o UT we go to application
sorry item seven mr. Chairman I had five
houses outside the village boundary went
to on appeal which was refused by this
committee this week and the inspector
said they're close enough simple is that
yeah there we go I'm happy two minutes
three minute break we can reconvene very
very quickly okay
okay she's not on this that's it
okay can we reconvene the meeting that
we've got everybody else of course
councillor Perry's not on the committee
for this particular application no hang
on having said the word reconvening
where's Richard gun okay well good two
seconds long
okay right so Alex I'm seven page 55
this is application reference 17 / 2 0 3
2 3 9 / vary and is Ashley farm the
hollows long Pompton ships not staff and
is the application to vary condition 1
of planning permission 16 / 0 to 9 7 2 /
r.e.m presenting officer Harrison
wheelers again Allison over to you
likes to the southern side of the
village of long Compton at the local
location shown by the black dot the site
is within the AO and be built outside
the conservation area there's a public
footpath that runs along the northern
edge of the site the northernmost tip of
the existing access is a registered
village green and is also within the
highlight highway verge here is an
aerial view of the site showing the
application site in the center of the
picture yep the agricultural buildings
shown have been removed and the
development of five houses is now well
advanced the site lies at a lower level
than old hill with a wooded embankment
running along the eastern edge of the
site separating it from the road a new
access into the site has been created
replacing the previous ramped access
from old hill beyond the sight
boundaries there are allotments to the
north this slide shows the existing
approved layout the new access our old
hill and the right the right of way
along the northern boundary the old
access on the northern tip is to be
landscape with a footpath
this application seeks to vary condition
number one of the revert reserved
matters which approved the landscaping
details and levels the new proposals
involved increasing the surface level of
a section of the public right-of-way
which runs along the southern side of
the northern boundary the effect of the
works would be to reduce the drop
between the new access road and the
public right-of-way along this section
the works would also allow the approved
footpath to adopt a lesser gradient than
would otherwise have been the case the
changing ground level on the northern
boundary would be supported with
retaining gabions filled with Cotswold
stone extending under the footpath for
approximately 33 metres with a short
return of approximately 5 metres ahead
will be planted within the application
site in front of the gabions to screen
them from the neighboring allotments the
1.5 meter foot way would be
reconstructed with compacted stone with
grass verge on the south side and a 1.2
meter high post and rail fence on the
northern side and the fence would return
for a short way along the western side
of the old access Drive it is intended
to create an opening in the stone road
side boundary wall to give the users
improved access to the right-of-way
all the signposts would be reinstated
this slide shows proposed sections
through the new access and the public
footpath the gabions colored buff would
extend under the public footpath and the
height of the gabions reduces as the
footpath proceeds up the hill at most
the gabions are shown to be
approximately one meter in the northeast
corner at fp3
a mixed native hedgerow would be planted
in front of the gabion to soften the
view from the allotments there would be
a postal rail fence running along the
edge of the footpath this is illustrated
in this slide which shows a typical
section so the allotments would be to
the left-hand side of the slide with the
boundary delineated by the previously
approved post and rail fence here is the
hedgerow and here are the gabions
extending under the footpath here grass
up to a foot path and another slope up
to the new site access
this slide shows the current view along
the old access which is to be landscaped
and this shot this slide shows the
current view along the northern boundary
application site on the right allotments
on the left this slide shows the current
view along the right of way running
uphill along the northern boundary the
ground levels in the picture are not the
finished levels the final slide shows
the proposed stone in a gabion basket on
the site the stone used on the houses
and the house is shown in the background
this has been recently received and has
been the subject of recent consultation
the photograph below shows the existing
wall along old Hill mr. chairman there
is an update on the recommendation long
Compton Parish Council have been have
considered the gabion sample filled with
the Cotswolds limestone stone in the
picture which has now been erected on
the site they have object still object
to the stone sample as the officer
recommendation would be to approve the
stone sample the matter is being
referred to planning committee to
consider the stone sampling gabion so
there is therefore a revised
recommendation to include the approval
of the boundary treatments including the
stone sample and gabions on the northern
boundary thank you thanks Alison okay
our first speaker then counsel Janet
Blackwell please from long Thompson
Parish Council
welcome cancer Blackwell thank you for
waiting so you have three minutes if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end and I'll give you a warning at
ten at the last ten seconds if that's
okay over to you
good evening the parish council object
to this application to begin with the
committee report we have three concerns
regarding the description of the site it
was not an unused site and agricultural
contractor and a carpenter used the
buildings and there is a permanent
resident in the mobile home
the original access was not ramped
photograph one shows the original access
before any development the register
village green extends beyond the tip of
the original access see photograph 2 map
of the village green from the Commons
registration act concerns of this have
been raised with the applicant and a
planning officer on a previous occasion
we do appreciate the effort that has
been made with the stone gabions
however with little more effort
something more closely resembling
photographs 3 & 4 could be achieved
while or measly bitters are facing and
infill or backfill with whatever's to
hand however the description and
positioning of the proposed gabions
fencing and hedging in the report and on
the submitted drawings is confusing and
unclear bearing in mind the existing
hedge bordering the allotments belongs
to the Parish Council on the face of it
the proposal seems to be two fences and
two hedges which seems a little
excessive it also begs the question how
would this be maintained and by whom
likewise how and who would maintain the
embankment from the ramp to tarmac
footpaths to the grain level alongside
the allotment boundary own 4 cm
photograph 5 which shows the proposed
footpath it would appear just proposed
to tarmac this new footpath not we would
suggest the best sight surface in an AO
MB particularly as it will be very
conspicuous and such as grass Creek
might be a better option the footpath
had also crossed a substantial portion
of the register village green in front
of the alot
this is illegal according to government
information on managing village greens
and has already been infringed with the
installation of utilities this is used
extensively with parish canes permission
by allotment holders and walkers to park
safely and without impeding traffic on
old Hill the Kirk Council does not feel
that this landscaping sits well in this
situation and is not in the public
interest thank you any questions for the
parish council no that case counts
black/off thank you very much for your
time our next speaker is mr. Keith
Williams please the agent to the
applicant
welcome mr. Williams you also have three
minutes if you remain seated for any
questions at the end over to you
good evening as you've heard and seen
the developments on the site is now well
advanced and a new vehicle or access has
been formed to the public highway the
approved scheme includes taking up the
old access Drive which you've seen on
the photographs to the former farm yard
and the formation of a new term apt
footpath with landscape verges in its
place it has been decided however that
it would bless to increase ground levels
on a section of the old access Drive so
that the gradient of the new footpath up
to the access road which has been built
is easier for petitions to use the
ground to either side of the new
footpath would be graded as appropriate
these the increase in ground levels does
not affect the registered village green
to the north of the site increasing the
height of the ground also allows the
improvement of the public footpath which
runs along the northern boundary of the
site the alignment of the public
footpath is not affected by the scheme
and the County Council has agreed to the
current proposals the works involve the
length of retaining wall and up the
suggestion of the parish council it has
been decided to use gabion walling you
have seen details of the walling
and the Cotswolds limestone to be used
and need to point out that the photos
were submitted to show the type in color
of the stone not how the warning would
be caused I wish to stress that the
stone within the baskets would be laid
in a professional manner reflecting
local tradition the walling would be set
away from the boundary of the site to
allow the planting of hedging in front
of it this hedging would supplement the
existing vegetation which I have to say
is abyss gapi along that one boundary
with the Ilan's post and rail fencing is
to be erected along the northern
boundary of the site as required by the
earlier planning permission post and
rail fencing is also to be erected along
the top of the gabion more linked for
safety reasons the proposed hedging
would be between the two lines of
fencing and in time will grow through
the maintenance of the public footpath
will rest with the County Council and as
part of the agreement with that
authority the developer will make a
community some payment towards the
maintenance of it in conclusion I
believe the proposals improve public
accessibility to the site and the use of
the public footpath they also enhance
the visual amenities of the site and its
locality including the village green I
ask you to grant a planning permission
thank you thank you mr. Williams any
questions good evening
you've heard of the parish council they
couldn't approve the color-coding was
that any debate about the choice of
color that you used or was it something
that this is the appropriate choice
existing the stone chosen is Cotswolds
limestone it's therefore widely used in
the local area and you will have seen
from the photograph that's just been
slid up the photo slid up the screen and
that it matches very closely with a
stone used on the houses
we therefore feel it is the most
appropriate stone to use in this
locality yes hey further questions mr.
Williams thank you very much for time
okay and we go to our final oops sorry
mr. Williams no no okay imagery of the
site yeah we can have to be put on but
we can also look at that in points of
clarification later on we go to our ward
member now councillor gray okay over to
you unlike the last my ward this time
I'm speaking in support of the parish
council in objects and the application
is true chairman this development has
caused difficult relations between the
developer and the parish council this
application doesn't appear to make those
relations any easier the parish council
takes great pride in the appearance of
the village they helped to introduce
Neighborhood Development Plan for long
Compton as well as a parish plan and
village design statement and they take a
lively interest in planning matters the
the parish council as you've heard is
not satisfied by these proposals and the
confusion over fencing and hedging and
the location of these changes on on the
on the village green is also disputed
the location is disputed by the parish
council I believe the community have
placed their trust in the parish council
through that NDP process and I think
it's unacceptable to be putting through
changes like this against the wishes of
the parish council without first going
the extra mile to see if appropriate
solutions can be found thank you Thank
You councillor gray any questions for
the ward member no thank you very much
right let's good points of clarification
should we start with council fielding if
we could have a quick look at the Google
Earth
shows the lay of the land so to speak
did you have a particular question about
that counsel Philip I think that's about
as good as we're gonna get Alison can
you show us roughly what the green is
sorry in terms of navigating if you look
at the shape of the allotments and the
subdivision of the allotment lot months
the access road starts roughly in the
center up the center line here roughly
about here and if I should show you one
on this plan this plan shows the
allotments which are green the
application site which is the purple
color
the highways extents is the buff color
and the village green boundary is level
with the edge of the highway extents
lined there so the village green just is
that very tip so we're looking in this
application at this boundary along here
and a very short return of five meters
just in this bit yeah
would I be right in saying it's not what
we would understand traditionally as a
village green as being a large open
space where you'd hold a fate or
something like that it's just it's
basically a virgin sea so it's just a
highway verge in front of the allotments
and on the opposite side of the road as
well it's kind of verge oh okay Counsell
Williams you indicated
there's been coming up the gradient of
this potful part is going to be built or
access road or whatever it is tell you
is this going to be it's the gradient
again we've all convenient for people
who walk then appears behind the site
the public footpath Rose quite steeply
up to the top of the hill and it it
dropped down into the site and then rose
up out of the site back onto old Hill so
so it came down hill in this direction
and then rose up again up towards the
road here and it comes pretty much come
straight through there's a wall running
along here and there was a style here
which was overgrown most people I
suspect used the existing farm access
along here to get onto the main road
rather than climb the style so the
proposal is to change the levels along
this boundary to make to raise the level
of the footpath along here so there's
not such a steep gradient down into the
site and then back out again so it would
be easier to use any other points of
clarification councillor fielding but
the reasons to be able to learn mobility
vehicles or is it just convenience for
the footpath well if you're going to do
that you can tell you a some of the
character of a footpath across country
if you is it really for mobility
vehicles or that type of or the elderly
who get onto this part and when we
consulted the rights of my officer they
were they wanted the style not to be re
to be put back in because they wanted
the the gap to be left open so people
who could have a greater degree of
access through up onto the right-of-way
from the road so that would enable
people with mobility probably
to to get up to get to access the path
more easily I suspect one of the reasons
was for introducing the change in levels
was to make the change from the access
road here shown underneath the car not
so steep down to the footpath level so
it is a relatively shallow incline here
and a relative shallow incline here this
drop will be to large degree which faces
the allotments will be softened with a
new head next native hedgerow along that
boundary okay any other points of
clarification socially out of the debate
we would like to start
councillor Williams I can't really see
any reason why we should not support the
application they seemed seventy-eight
advantages they just outweigh the
disadvantages been outlined to us by the
parish council I do feel we should
support this application I'd be happy to
support their location thank you I'll
take that as a proposition castle bones
it looks to me is there an improvement
for people like me and others that can't
walk very well turn along the footpath
and where there's a style so as far as
I'm concerned although I don't normally
support councillor Williams but I have
tonight the second on probably because
he's back on the committee but I can see
no real problem that as far as I can see
it's an improvement thank you and back
to stone it looked to me if the offices
that make the decision on the stone and
as far as I can see it looked to be
local stone it for compromise we do have
a revised recommendation that would
allow us to make
decision on the stone as well to know so
that's part of it counts a crumb yeah I
had three concerns that occurred what
the parish council said regarding the
maintenance in the boundary treatment
the potential effect on the village
green of a footpath and the stone and
the gabion was gay beyond you say gay
beyond I was how you go beyond all over
and I was satisfied by the response from
the agent I thought was reasonable so my
initial trepidation regarding this has
been removed it's also our note that's
the three I think there was three
applications three objections from local
residents and I believed I'm no longer
pertinent because the use of concrete
panels are no longer proposed so again I
appreciate the work that the post case
or does and I'm afraid I will be going
with officers okay we have a proposition
we don't yet have a seconder
I'm happy to second I think on this
occasion oh okay well that counts the
bombs go for the second dinner how you
enjoys that okay so we we proposed
letters to check your proposing council
William so that we go for the revised
recommendation so you are content with
the condition about the stone okay in
councillor Barnes
certainly okay so the recommended I
should revise recommendation is found on
the update sheet so you can all be aware
of that if you vote all those in favor
of granting this show thank you
therefore the committee results to grant
application reference 17 / 0 3 2 3 9 /
very and go to item 8 on tonight's
agenda found on page 67 okay this is
application reference 17 / 0 to 9 1 2 /
ful in is 4
old school vicarage road maps and finish
the provision of an additional temporary
external accommodation to provide two
new rooms for one-to-one long space of
the pupils of schools pupils presenting
officer daily Wilson Tim over to you
Thank You chair so this is the
application site
I could win naps on the hill this is the
application site outlined in red this
includes the school and the school plan
filled to the rear this are existing and
proposed elevations to the top is
elevation of the existing shipping
container use of storage on the site and
below is the posed temporary classroom
this is the existing site plan the
existing storage unit is where the mass
market is just here and this is the
proposed application site site plan the
proposed cap in again when the mouse is
and also relocated parking space located
shaded in gray just here this is a plan
showing the vehicle tracking into the
proposed relocated parking space and
these are the site photos so looking
towards the existing pre temporary
prefer crated cabin gesture and as the
existing shipping container there's a
close-up view of the shipping container
and this is the access to the school
thank you right thank you daily our
first speaker it's gonna be counselor
Williams on this one because no one else
is registered so board member straight
over to you
seven first one must apologize for lapse
in parish council they would have come
to last week but this will meet some
snow in the meantime and they really
could not organize to go here today the
school is there you can't say it's not
there if the application was to consider
this whole site at a new site I'm sure
we wouldn't grant it Knapton is a very
unique village is built on the side of a
very steep hill every road is a one mate
well it seems to me and access is very
restricted now how many times we heard
the school saying oh yes there's cars in
the morning and cars and evening but
meantime it's all deserted they might
have sufficient for the number of staff
from the school that we work there in
the mornings and evenings is very
congested it closes confusion to the
people who live in napkin it's always
been a problem you see I think the
school is not being functioning as a
school and it's noticeable have a more
traffic move already 24 hours a day but
the reconvening of the school and change
around I realize we can't stop what's
being done but something's not do
something to control the parking make it
more efficient
just hit they got approval in 2011 take
alterations for the site access and the
provision of 16 finished parking spaces
well since that time the world's moved
on
I just think myself I think it could be
better use of the space available with a
workout system system than just saying
this is what we're doing getting on with
it
I'm not against the provision of the
school or the baby cars there but it's
the consequences of the school being
there and what it impacts on the
residents the parish council supports
the proposal would just say what are we
going to do about is this an opportunity
for us just
in efficient off-road parking system
because certainly they have people come
across their ballpark in the school
grounds
so I don't know what we can say about
that but we ensure that everything is
within the accompli for the parking all
our district it's better for the
residents of baptists how they can live
with this problem but we all got schools
in our villages and we just know what
it's like between nine and quarter past
and past three and four o'clock I found
that to my vision I support the
application by just concerned about the
parking implications of the site itself
thank you can't silence do you have any
questions for the ward member in this
application that case counsel names
thank you
okay points of clarification do we have
any should we go to the debate that's
the cramp this is my came to counsel
Ward are do goats and Upton Park and so
on the regular basis I also my daughter
works at school around the corner so
dance taxi okay well very often goes
first this application saw it on a
regular basis the problem with sight is
this castle Wiggum says as it gets
congested and taxis delivering that the
children to school attend up and tend to
end up being parked on the road in and
out of the path and does actually narrow
the road quite significantly and
sometimes shall we saw the taxi drivers
don't stop in the most appropriate place
I shall be tactful there for once so
whilst I support the application
and obviously it's a temporary
application for three years and the salt
restoration after again a support that I
think we I would hope they see not to
see some strengthening of parking
arrangements on site which makes less
impact on the road just outside bearing
in mind the amount of taxes actually
deliver the children there so support it
but hopefully we can strengthen some of
the conditions to improve the traffic
situation from the highways point of
view Thank You councillor Perry Thank
You chair and from a planning
perspective I'm struggling to find how
we can put in conditions to alleviate
the problems that both the Ward member
and my colleague or my left has has has
mentioned particularly is this
additional temporary accommodation
appears it's to provide rooms for one to
one learning space it's not it doesn't
identify that it's the school is
expanding hugely so we're getting going
to get a lot of traffic additional
traffic so I can't see a planning
Reavers reason to refuse this however
perhaps I can just add a recommendation
that the ward member perhaps and the
Parish Council
get together with the head of the school
and say that the school can actually
implement some new parking arrangements
for staff and pupils yeah it's the bonds
every school but well first school has a
major problem in fact a couple of months
ago they had a burglary and the burglars
decided to do it a quarter past three
and they couldn't get their van out and
all the kids found of the police so
laugh as you might but they'd obviously
picked the wrong time the people had
gone to Tesco which they always go at
the same time got all the furniture
loaded up and of course they couldn't
get out
so it's like that at every school but if
we can get cooperation between the
County Council and the school to get
something address I think that is the
way forward and I support the
application I think I'll have my
thoughts which as counts Perry knows
even a Wells but we have we all have
schools but Wells boss experience is the
same issue with which she's been going
on now for decades and decades we'll
never fix it I think in Wells Vaughn's
case but I think it this isn't really
the forum to try and work out you know
school traffic management programs it's
to do with County Council and board
members and the head teachers I think I
can't see a reason not to allow this
proposal to go through we're also in
favor of this no one's actually proposed
to yeah I'm happy to propose it from the
chair do I have a seconder
- counselor Perry so it's not without
sympathy that I would say that for the
to the local board member and hope
counts willing to take that message back
to the parish council for us as well
that we do have a lot of sympathy with
what your the difficulty of facing but I
don't think this is the forum to address
it really right should go to the vote
all those in favor of granting for the
committee results to grant application
17 / 0 - 9 1 2 / ful item line on page
75 so there are two application
references here this is 17 / 0 3 6 o 6 /
ful and 17 / 0 3 6 7 / lbc and as for 13
to 15 high street ships no staff and is
for the change of use of the 1st or 2nd
floor officers - to apartments and
associated internal works presenting
officer Allison once again well to you
13 to 15 high street ships OnStar is a
gray 3 story great story three story
grade 2 listed building and lies within
the Conservation Area
here's a recent aerial view of the site
showing the application site outlined in
red the block plan shows the
ground-floor shop to the front hatched
red with vacant 1st and 2nd floor
offices above there's a one bit bedroom
dwelling and a 3 bedroom 2 B&B to the
rear with separate rear access and
garage into the rear for 2 cars which is
hatched green this slide shows the
ground-floor shop pedestrian access from
high street is from 3 access points a
passageway either side of the shop and
the shop doorway itself this slide shows
the proposals for the 1st and 2nd floor
planning permission and listed building
consent is being sought for the change
of use of the first and second floors
floor offices - two apartments a one bed
and a two-bed and associated internal
alterations the change of use is not
permitted development in this instance
as the building in the in question is
listed the alterations required to form
an additional flat for all internal the
external appearance of the premises
remains unchanged unchanged this slide
shows the front elevation this slide
shows the rear rear elevation of the
building with rear facing windows on the
first and second floors
this slide shows the view from the first
floor kitchen diner and this slide shows
the view from the second floor living
room and the second floor kitchen diner
the seating area outside the B&B is
approximately 15 meters from the second
floor living room window
there is no carpet car parking provided
with the app within the application site
this slide shows the location of
available parking west street car park
here where there are 27 parking spaces
maximum stay 24 hours free of charge and
there are also along here car parking
spaces in front of the application site
on High Street which are limited to two
hours during the day between 8 a.m. and
6 p.m. for unrestricted after 6 p.m. mr.
chairman there are no updates and the
recommendation is to approve the
applications for the reasons detailed in
the report thank you Thank You Allison
our first speaker is mr. Andy Murphy the
applicant agent
welcome mr. Murphy thank you for waiting
so you have three minutes to remain
seated for any questions at the end
I will over to you Thank You chairman
this building was historically one house
and in the year 2000 had permission to
subdivide the upper floors into four
flats that permission was not
implemented later the upper floors
fronting High Street were converted into
offices and the rear of the building
became a bed-and-breakfast for eighteen
years
there was only one office tenant and
they left in January 2017
despite marketing the premises with
Peter Carr Clarke encode for over six
months no offers were received for a new
office tenant the rooms are small
compartmentalised and provide no
dedicated parking or disabled access
therefore it is not surprising that an
office tenant cannot be found it is
proposed that the offices revert to
residential use this change will have
negligible impact on the local economy
because of the small floor space
involved and office use has occurred for
only a short period one issue is parking
there has never been off road parking
spaces associated with the building that
did not stop residential subdivision
being granted in the year 2000 or change
of use to offices granted in 2009
visitors tend to park legally on the
high street or the 24-hour free public
car parked behind a floor space
calculation shows that the offices
generate 15 parking spaces and the two
proposed flats generate three parking
spaces in other words the offices
generate five times more parking demand
compared with two flats I expect that
the future occupiers of these two flats
will either not own a car or will rent a
garage somewhere else in town another
issue is residential immunity the back
of the building operates a bed and
breakfast business no additional windows
are proposed
so overlooking the rear courtyard will
be similar to when offices
occupying the upper floors there is no
direct overlooking of habitable windows
and so there will be sufficient privacy
between existing and future residents of
the building finally there is no
objection from the Town Council and I
ask you to support the officer
recommendation and grant planning
permission and listed building consent
thank you thank you mr. Murphy any
questions for the applicants agent
councillor Crump office spaces in the
town you said though it was empty from
January 2017 and for six months and then
despite being pocketed by Mr Clarke
Peter Clarke
there was no office what what's the
office space is at a premium in town or
just one day but you've done any market
research as well well we've left that in
the hands of Peter Clarke Inc oh I can't
really answer your question directly but
so you can funnily enough the markets
here Peter Clarke & Co their offices are
on the ground floor the building just a
coincidence so there are available there
is available office floor space in in
town it's not premium because one of the
problems is there's no disabled access
you can't be threw up the floor offices
it's narrow staircases it's difficult to
get up and the officers are fairly small
this is not premium offices floor space
cats for fielding can you put your
microphone on and the second question is
we keep referring to the bed and
breakfast what is the access and where
is the access to the bed and breakfast I
can do with that last part first the
access is from the rear so although it's
one is regarded as one building is
actually in sewer ownerships so you see
the green hatching on the plan so
they've got two parking spaces at the
rear for
Bed and Breakfast well if there's a flat
and a bed-and-breakfast it's it's all
owned by the same person so their access
is from the rear they have two parking
spaces and a garage I believe with
regard to parking so of garages for rent
it would be quite some walk for that in
the town center there simply aren't
garages there so I'm thinking about on
the edge the edges in the suburban
neighborhoods of ship stone I haven't
done any research as to what the
availability is but I'm sure if one made
an effort one could find a vacant garage
space councillor balance well we've got
this picture on the bottom car park or
to the left
yes is this 24-hour that's right here
and have you got to walk all the way
around to get to it or you want to get
to the you would have to walk all the
way yes you can't take a shortcut
through the bed-and-breakfast because
that's in in separate ownership always
so say if you were visiting these two to
propose flats you've needed to walk does
it were down and round yes so you can't
come down to Bed and Breakfast and Gary
online
we can't you you physically can you can
go through the Ben breakfast but because
it's in separate ownership we can't
deliver a direct access okay so no
further questions mr. Murphy thank you
very much
we now go to our ward member councillor
st.
welcome counsel saying thank you for
being patient you have five minutes I'll
try and death gets to the point quickly
um interesting presentation for mr.
Murphy I would have expected though all
this assessment of available parking
spaces to come from the case officer or
the presenting officer not from a
representative those trying to prove a
point because as the please been
conceded the available garage spaces in
ships that are virtually nil and it will
be some considerable distance away and
this presents my main problem the other
issue before I get on to parking is the
bed and breakfast behind I had quite
serious representation from them uh over
these issues and I would have expected
in the presentation you to have sort of
seen you know 45-degree angles etc
except as a trite description in the
officers report but it's an urban area
so you must expect a bit of overlooking
that might be true in Manhattan but this
is downtown ship Stern and effectively
we have a fairly rural ambience in this
part now let's have a look at these
parking spaces because the parking
spaces provided by this council and
you've heard me say this before are
provided for shoppers and workers not
for residents and I know every summer he
gets his figures from but the report
suggests that there might be a
particular saving on spaces but quite
we're comparing them to what happened in
two thousand or even 2009 is very
different because there's been a
considerable amount of house building in
shifts and since then and that has
generated an awful lot of extra local
demand for car parking and I'll
guarantee you at 7:30 in the morning
when I Drive down that road by my
Stratford Herald half-past seven
morning I'll have a hell of a job
getting a place to park in even the two
hours loss because they just don't exist
they don't exist in the evening they
don't exist during the shopping time
it's always fall in the evening it's
full of revelers and diners in the
various town centre restaurants now what
I'm concerned about is the way this has
been presented on page 77 it refers to
the Neighborhood Development Plan at
which it says is now independent
examination I stopped write the exam
independent examination is complete and
we have the report from the examiner so
if we were going to mention that why was
that report not mentioned in this
particular presentation and secondly it
talks about and Richard referred to this
earlier public consultation on guardians
because drop parking standards were
endorsed on the 15th of January planning
policy manager did bring the draft
parking Sanders ahead of the
consultation to cabinet on the 15th of
January and he did so to give them some
weight because he felt that the
committee's needed some stronger
guidance and therefore this report
dismisses that cabinet report as having
little weight I'm asking you to
reinstate the weight because I don't
think that Cabinet decision has been
given any particular weight at all and
the issue is you used to be able to
consider local car parks when assessing
this sort of application and now you
can't because that wording was taken out
and I can identify the cabinet members
that were quite keen on that
so therefore chairman we actually don't
have a parking solution for residents
here and we cannot keep granting town
center residences there's been about
three in the last so many months and
indeed and pacify the local need for
parking now we have a situation where
mr. Murphy's is the town council don't
object the Town Council said no
representation that's different - no
objection
I happen to know them as I work with
them and they don't actually object on
parking because we haven't sorted out
the blooming guidance yet in their view
and that is why an effectively if you
study there 30 seconds if you study
their responses they're always saying no
representation so you must draw your own
conclusions from that and not assume
there is tremendous disquiet from the
Town Council about parking situations as
I've described them now I'll do it I'm
totally shut up thank you you have three
seconds left okay any questions for the
ward board members questions yes sir
[Music]
objection one object on page seven
identify that chairman we can come back
at the point verification that's okay
yeah there was a name I might be able to
but there's nothing that's fair enough
any other questions from the ordinance
does have serious representations about
parking in ships done it would be
advisable for us to know in writing of
this concerns irrespective of what they
feel of the parking guidance that we've
been talking about so at least we know
we can gauge the sense that the theme
was of the Town Council
I'm not disputing that it's been said
and on substituting that you've heard it
but it would be advisable if actually
formally objected I'll actually put
something
writing to say about chairman council
Crump makes a very valid point and I can
assure him and the rest of the committee
that I've done this I would like them to
come along and express their views
instead of hiding them away instead of
me feeling that I'm the flag waver
sitting here on my own and therefore
struggling with arguments to take back
to the town council Council Perry thank
you good evening counselor st. and I
just wanted your views I mean it's
obviously highlighted in the report but
I'd like your views because obviously
there is a parking issue which you're
really concerned about can you just
explain the impact of parking in the
town from your perspective as if it was
an office moving to to two apartments
because I'm I'm struggling you might
disagree with the numbers but surely the
current situation of an office if they
were to get tenants for the for the
office it would actually be an increased
number of vehicles vis a vie a
residential when in fact actually could
could be quite likely that those people
who who were living in the building
wouldn't actually be parked in the ships
turned car park because they could be
working elsewhere why complex question
that's right
they could be based in the office and
working elsewhere I would justify them
parking in our car parks if they've come
into work that's the point that I've
made if they were residents they might
actually have a greater impact I don't
believe the numbers of mr. Murphy
throughout the committee they really
were effectively quite preposterous
so consequently we have a situation
whereby it could be two or three car
parking space is taken up by workers or
two or three car parking spaces by
residents but effectively we want people
to work in the town and we want them to
have facilities we want people to come
and shop in the town we don't want
residents blocking up parking spaces for
shoppers and workers that's the simple
point and I'm sure the Town Council
would agree with me if they were here
well no further questions for the ward
member thank you very much right points
of clarification now do we have any the
only one I wanted to ask probably to
Mesa about it was raised earlier about
the weight of consideration we can give
to the emerging parking recommendations
as was brought up at the cabin recently
yeah yes I know the plumbing officers
actually stated that in their reports
and at the committee meeting after it
went to cabinet I actually confirmed
that the parking offenders should be
given the limited wait I have no idea
and it wouldn't be in my process to
actually have submitted it to cabinet
first I would have gone out to
consultation first before submitting it
to cabinet that's the way I think
thought the process should have been
done because it's going out for
consultation I still believe that there
could be comments that could come back
on that and therefore I would give it
limited wait until those comments have
been received points of clarification
hey Elsa no shrio to the debate who
wants to start with this one councillor
bonds I'm not here to upset counts the
same but as far as I can see there's no
real there is a problem with parking the
cars wherever you are at the moment and
if we do if we stop we refuse this
application more as they come along the
extent of the village dies and if they
residential if you like they may be
parking overnight and the people that
are moving in to come in shopping aren't
there so as far as I can see there could
be a swing to giving actually more
spaces than there is if there are
offices because the more people working
in the offices means the more people
can't shop so it's a swings and
roundabouts and as far as I'm concerned
we need to approve the application thank
you Calipari Thank You chair I think my
main issue with with this particular
application is that I don't have strong
enough planning reasons to to refuse it
because of the situation where we have
draft SD parking standards and whilst I
I have sympathy with councillor st. in
his views in my day job we don't have a
problem in letting apartments in ships
turn without parking and there are a
number of young people who and more
elderly people who want to live in the
town center and keep a vibrancy to the
town after all the shops have closed and
there are a number of restaurants there
as I say whilst I do have sympathy on on
the side of the parking I don't feel we
have robust planning reasons to refuse
it on this basis on the principle that
the draft SD parking schemes carries
little weight as highlighted by our
legal officer councillor Crump nets and
counts the fielding Aparri they
appreciate the fact from the parking
point of view you can only go to a well
for so many times the parking car parks
could become fallen not for their
intended purpose but with the premium
width of the pit when the previous case
is on at Morton moral
enlighten there was a grand Swan of
opinion there was a lot of evidence it
was well researched there was a lot of
support it was one argued that there was
a need for that I don't seem to see this
here along say if we've got the parish
council here to say this is the third
application we've had recently that it's
going to potentially be using our SDC
car park
we're having trouble attracting people
into the tire etc and it's no there's
nobody here and that's what I find
disappointing there's been one objection
which turns out to be the same one
that's objectives cats the scientist as
a objected here according to the case
officer and there's been no there's no
groundswell of opinion to say we don't
want this because they're like a park
because it's not suitable
so therefore what stop sympathy for the
council council the site I will become
with officers recommendation Thank You
council fielding have we had the
question answered about the light and
you could have raised it as a point of
clarification I'm happy to trap it to
ask if we can go about ålesund it
do you have anything to offer us on on
the lighten bed and breakfast and the
bed and breakfast is accessed from the
rear of the application site completely
independently of the front of the of the
three-story building that we're
considering so in terms of it's got its
own parking it's got its own garage it's
got its own courtyard so in a way it's
completely separate in that regard the
in terms of overlooking the the distance
from distances from the upstairs windows
on the first and second floor that face
towards the back a sufficient distance
away to comply with the
the recommendations that we normally use
so I don't have a problem
yes counsel Williams and then we'll move
to the I'm concerned because there is a
neighborhood plan approved this proposal
that seem to affect the neighborhood
plan just a question I would have
thought that we will found out about
that they don't let her mentioned sure
we've not got a proposition and so I do
need it formally proposed a lot of
people said I'd like to grant the
application I think I agree councillor
Crump will propose do I have a seconder
yes thank you
can we deal with both in one go you can
you proposing both of these applications
thank you
and counselor bounds are you also second
in both thank you we'll go to the vote
those in favor of granting both
applications and those against and
abstentions
therefore the putti results to grant
application references 17 / 0 3 6 0 6 /
ful and 17 / 0 3 607 / l bc our final
item item 10 on page 87 is application
reference 17 / 0 3 4 5 8 / very his
galley house what cut road for Eddie
etting ttan is for the variation of
condition 5 of Planning Commission it's
already planned push news amending is 12
/ 0 0 3 9 v / ful this is the temporary
lift of restrictive condition 3 years
presenting officer Daley Wilson daily
never to you again Thank You chair if
the application is to lift condition 5
which is restrictive occupancy condition
so the application 2012 was for a
woodworkers dwelling as part of the
dairy farm this plan shows the location
of the farm it's just to the northeast
of full ready this is the rule workers
well in itself outlined in red just
above is seafoam complex these other
plans crude in 2012 for the rural
workers dwelling and this is a plan
showing the the wider farm site
so again outlined in red is the wall
workers to an approved 2012 there's a
farm complex there and there is a
farmhouse related to the farm complex
and this is a photo of the application
site this is the main dwelling
councilors may recall in December last
year two rural workers drones were
approved as part of the garage
conversion just here thank you okay we
know any alleged speakers the ward
members away but councillor kettle doing
excellent jobs like an understanding in
other word members is going to read a
state from cattle low cattle
I'm purely reading the woman's message
the applicant tried to meet isn't here
so I'm less informed than I was earlier
on believing chair members the committee
I apologize I cannot join you due to be
on a course in London that is of course
myself I'm keen support our rural
economy encourage the continued
expansion of mr. Walker's dairy farm
I support the applicants request and the
office recommendation to grant a
temporary suspension of the restrictive
condition a stage of the officers report
galle house is currently surplus to
requirements of the dairy enterprise and
needs to be rented out otherwise it will
have to be left vacant strangely the
current occupant was working on farms
apparently does not meet the council's
definition currently of an agricultural
worker
we have real assurances from mr. Walker
that he believes that the farm will have
expanded to a level with the next three
years to employ a full-time farm manager
who could then live in galle house so
the problem is is currently there is a
timing issue whilst the business
develops the applicant and parish
council have engaged and I understand
the parish council do not wish to stand
in the way of expansion and progress at
treehouse farm their concern was
regarding the wording of the application
and that the restrictive time would be
reinstated after three years I believe
that we're all the similar positive and
supportive mindset regardless
application I would therefore request
the committee to support the officer
recommendation to allow the temporary
lifting of the outcome for all persons
evolution many thanks spoken on behalf
of councillor thank you very much to
both of you excellent we can't ask any
questions so thank you points of
clarification I suppose on tonight do we
have any council Williams
it's hard to see on this on this clamp
but just to the a mind said it's about
the time we have met the council Stagner
other point is clarification
should we go to debate yes awesome Thank
You chairman I'm completely supportive
this I can't see any reason why we
wouldn't do it and it's the Parish
Council who objected on here I think we
should just vote to accept the officers
recommendation I take that as a
proposition do I have a seconder well
let's go councillor fielding even beat
interested in there I'm happy with that
all those in favor of granting therefore
the committee results to grant
application 17 / 0 3 4 5 8 / very that's
the end of the meeting we can close
thank you very much everybody